hello good evening this is Ian King live
I'm Sara Hewson Debenhams has today
confirmed the news we reported on this
program yesterday it will shut 50 stores
a third of its of state and up from the
ten it previously announced that means
around four thousand people may lose
their jobs the company booked to record
loss of four hundred and ninety two
million pounds mainly due to accounting
right downs with underlying profits of
thirty three million pounds the firm
hopes what it calls decisive action will
mark a turning point as the shares
rallied by seven percent today but after
having fallen by seventy five percent
this year the chief executive is Serge a
pusher and is here with me hello good
evening to you mr. Boucher is this the
last roll of the dice for Devin and
farthing you know what is important to
remember is that debenhams is a
profitable company happy you said it we
delivered thirty three million pounds
worth of profit before tax we generally
say fall still well yes we we generate
160 million pounds worth of EBD as well
so that the very large number that you
mentioned initially is a one of charge
it is a an accounting adjustment that
basically doesn't have an impact on the
cash flow of the company so I think it's
very important to remember that we are
solving company and we intend to to
remain sir a sovereign company but one
that needs to make massive changes to
remain so and that means a third of
stores to close a third of your estate
is to go are you confident that 50
stores is the final number because
originally it was 10 now it's 50 is that
going to continue to rise well you know
I think it's not a surprise that
customers are shopping less in stores
and more online and I think an
interesting number is that 30 of our
leases were actually signed before the
internet existed we therefore need to
take decisive action I think that we
have a clear vision of the future of
Debenhams we think it's a company that
needs to have about a hundred stores in
exciting shopping destinations we want
to have better stores a better shopping
experience on the flip side that means
that we will need to close a number of
stalls so over the next five years not
today because most of our stores are
steel profitable we will consider
closing down stalls
50 stores is a third of our state but
it's only 15% of our turnover and less
than 8% of our profit but that is going
to lead to job losses of around four
thousand well you know we have twenty
six thousand employees today and my goal
is to really protect as many jobs and as
many stores out as possible and that's a
promise I can do to my stall staff we
will really focus on preserving the jobs
in the company your biggest shareholder
Mike Ashley also the new owner of your
rival House of Fraser what are you
expecting from him well you know Sports
Direct is our largest shareholder and
we're very thankful they invested in the
company they're also a commercial
partner we operate a number stalls with
them and they have become one of our
large competitors as well I think that
we have constructive relationships and
we hope we can develop our commercial
relationship how concerned are you
though about suggestions he'll try an
engineer Debenhams collapse he'll a
swoop in and we'll have House of
Debenhams well I think that you know
he's said publicly that he's supportive
of us and we are working as I said
constructively on the commercial front
supportive of you as an independent or
supportive of you as part of his group
well that's a very good question you
should ask him we will indeed if we can
and the budget coming up on monday
philip hammond has said he wants to do
more to help the high street what do you
want to see from him well you know I'm
very clear that I am responsible for
making Debenhams successful I'm not
expecting the government to do that for
me what are we expecting from the
government is that they will set a level
playing field over the past year we paid
about 80 million pounds worth of
business rates this is not a level
playing field our London accessories
store paid five million pounds that's 20
percent upon last year five million
pounds is the equivalent of 200 jobs so
you want to cut in business rates to
compete against your former employer
Amazon will that level the playing field
for you
what we want is the tax setup to be
distributed I would say in a fair way
between all the players in the market
that's what we asking for and rescue
package that you've announced today rise
on the cooperation of your landlords
have those discussions begun are you
confident that you
well we have some very constructive
conversations I think a great example is
the store that we recently open in
Watford it's an extension of the center
it's a very exciting development it's a
great shopping destination we have
showcase in that store our new store
format that is really aimed at making
shopping social and exciting and
customers absolutely love it what makes
you think that this restructuring and
the new look stores that you're talking
about can save debenhams is there room
on the high street for you for House of
Fraser for John Lewis in this shrinking
High Street Market well you know I
wouldn't have come from Amazon to
Debenhams if I didn't really have
confidence in the high street I have
confidence in the integration between
bricks and mortar and digital this is
what our strategy is well you know we
have if you go to our Watford store
you'll see that we have an amazing
fitting room with a click try and buy
service that makes click and Collect so
much more pleasant and more convenient
for customers
Sergio Pasha thanks very much indeed for
joining you thank you